did you have like a dwarf friend like
that too or no I never knew I never knew
a [ __ ] and her like a little person
until the first one I have a mythical
met Brad wins the first one ever meant
till ya know he's one of my fair first
yeah yeah it's my very first I never met
him a little person wait wait wait
you've seen him before no we didn't have
a lot of that you know we didn't have
never saw a little person in Florida we
didn't have Asians or no no joke
we had like 1/8 like the joke I'm the
first joke I made when I came out to LA
and I met Asians for the first time
first night I mean I'm being dead
serious like no yeah I grew up in the
70s I grew up born 1972 so I grew up in
a time where just wasn't very diverse in
Florida especially was 71 so I was
around but not in Tampa that's true
there was Samuel Howe one God said that
one guy Wow and the first joke I'm
making a wooden even joke is a joke - it
was a thing that dr. ken it was a
sentence I said it dr. ken an older
Asian guy was in the hallway at the
Ontario improv with his wife and I hit
doctor can I go I think your parents are
trying to get in and and he goes I don't
know them and I went he's yours
he goes no it was their Japanese I go I
go what are they saying I don't know I
go what kind of what are they saying
yeah
that night I want to say just did you
know that Japanese people can't
understand Chinese people at all oh my
Italian Spanish like pantalones Bologna
I don't find that I don't find that
races at all you're doing science in
your mind all right when I was like
you're calculating and all that stuff
but I was a kid I just didn't know and
you're like I like and the only way you
know is to ask and all the way you got
to ask you can't let not ask well you
don't have to ask oh you could just read
Google you know that's that's why the
Middle East has so much turmoil is none
of those languages or even remotely the
same right which gets us to the new
Tubbs subject I'm dying to talk about
which was the truth the truth about a
poo oh yeah maybe something when you
said that earlier about poo yeah I have
no idea what the [ __ ] you're talking
about
what is it you can you help me wasn't
the title you know what's the title of
who is his name by it's really fancy
tree is it green by the way that's not
your appropriation yeah that's what the
crazy thing about how many these days so
this guy secret of on days by Appu that
what you're trying know it's the it's
the problem with Appu it's the it's
called a problem of poo by hero and I'm
not gonna try to attempt to say his last
name Excel just a Japanese guy no no no
he's Southeast Asia Asia Oh at the break
so no no what about right now Gilbert
you're embarrassing me no I'm a bear
this guy's a headliner here hero hir Oh
couldn't something a good but you know
[ __ ] but he what kinda mole oh yeah yeah
it's by the way I have to say this it's
it's problematic for a white comic to
talk about because it's something that
immediately all this is the biggest
problem I think right now is that not 11
up people are listening you know and so
as a 45 year old white guy I just tried
to listen I can go like the thing about
not knowing that Japanese people in
Chinese people didn't understand each
other yeah I really I wasn't meaning
hateful I was like I didn't know that I
really didn't know you really didn't
know that dude I did I didn't I love it
I didn't know one Asian person until I
was 26 years old I didn't know one Asian
person but you see he saw them around
like at a mall but yeah but I didn't
like you know I didn't wasn't like super
interactive like I was like hey man you
guys raisin I'm Burt you guys want to
meet up and yeah but could I would have
defended though to is is that um you
know what you were running into were
fresh off the boat people you know when
people come here from a different
country they they stick Asians that we
stick to ourselves right we have these
little meetings and you know like that
on the guy Joe song we they got that
shut up Virginia attack yeah they
couldn't get ahold of none of the news
media could get ahold of his parents to
interview them because the Asian
community Harvard them really and they
took him off the market and they left
and then they sent them into Korea and
no one could interview them or anything
that's how Asians are were very
secretive so badass
yeah you like that I wish I wish like I
saw a black panther and I was like I
party is like it was like I wish they
have one of these four white guys like
you know like why people don't like they
do it's just bad one but I think that's
I think that's like the Asian
communities like in New York when that
[ __ ] I think that's kind of cool I don't
want that to be lost in progress
I don't want agents to not be a team
yeah no no it's not coming out right is
it but can I just might want to I want
to say something I want to I want to say
that we don't assimilate enough also
okay I think that when you come to this
country right you should have you should
not just stick to your culture but to
reach your hand out and talk to African
Americans I think during the riots there
was no communication and it caused
division and the city burn on fire they
we should reach our hands out and I
think people should you know not close
themselves off no but what American
culture no but what about this though
how cool is it when you meet another
Korean person and you get and you share
something that you both
similarly shared in childhood that like
no one else knows about you're like I
don't I'm gonna but like did your mom
ever fold her clothes like this and
that's the thing the only Koreans do and
then you go oh my mom did that too and
then you're like oh remember this this
miss yeah like like white people don't
have that at all like there's nothing we
have nothing shimmer simile shared me
know like like I would spend the night I
went to I had his girlfriend Sarah
Hyland right and she lived in the South
Korean sir no she's white oh yeah she
was tall
why kind of rednecky kind of girl she's
really funny she was standup
anyway um I used to spend the night ma
we would go there to Louisville Kentucky
and I would in her her mom her
grandmother was like kind of racist a
little bit her parents were pretty
liberal but and I would wake up and it
smelled like my friend Craig's house
growing up which was a combination of
coffee apple pie to this baseball mitt
this is a bit right here this is all
three things at the same time this is
your house I wish I had to know you're
there is it so why people smell quite
him why do you smell like a like a
handful of different things yeah and
it's in there we don't go much out of
the spectrum that is [ __ ] hilarious
well no but Asians we don't go through
much of the spectrum our best friends
were Vietnamese and then you go into
their house like when they bought a new
house yeah and we went into their or
like it done smell like your house yet
you know every Korean household that
I've ever gone into they always have
kimchi a big concern in the fridge and
you know when you have like the filtered
water that filtered water always tastes
it has a hint of kimchi always we stay
there there's always a tub of kimchi
Mitch is the whole physics are Flynt
oh yeah like our Flint Michigan we don't
have painted water but we have kimchi
water service has that yeah we do have
that same vibe our kids went to 3rd
Street School on 3rd Street and like in
like Larchmont border of Koreatown wait
let me ask you this is a private school
no public school is back in the day
there don't go there anymore but it was
predominantly Korean right like the
kindergarten class was Korean immersion
so like your kid they won't because and
they taught math the way the Koreans
learn math is up by it by the way barely
listen to what I'm saying cuz I kind of
I don't know what I'm talking about yeah
but I'm but I think Korean maths a lot
like playing the violin ok yep disagree
what is saving the same way to play the
violin is how you learn math and Korean
and Asian math is easier than white math
don't take my word on this I kind of
listened we were you know let me see
what I'm gonna say ok all right and then
you can see known to call my wife window
clear why no because she would know what
I'm trying to say yeah but what you're
saying what I'm just saying is that that
numbers were a universal thing no no
it's not but it's how you learned the
math how you learn the math is very
different because surely in math was was
easier to understand and then
colonial math so they would teach them
math in Korean and it would and that's
why math scores were through the roof
and someone's got to have my back on
this because I or at least explain what
the kind of like how rocky trained and
Ivan Drago trained right right yeah
rocky trained in the forest with logs on
his back yes check Jason chickens yeah
the Ivan Drago had the futuristic yeah
and it is all based on the violin I know
it makes sense when you're playing music
you see a note you don't calculate what
the note is you go oh that's a B I had a
B so they the way I took Koo Mons is
three two you don't go what's three plus
two you go the combination three you
moans you [ __ ]
I was to my friend right with Sabaton
eyes and you made me look at a fool that
either guessed and I want you to
apologize right now mr. Christ share
apologize thank you
[ __ ] you knew I was really bad I cheated
so our kids couldn't do it either our
kids did either
alkylate yeah that's where I got by the
way that long story to get to this is
where I got introduced to kimchi the
Korean mom's was on Thanksgiving they do
a Thanksgiving feast but it was all
Korean food and so I first time I had
kimchi was that one of these
Thanksgiving feast when my daughter was
in kindergarten and man
kimchi connected with me it like
something I was so into it and so I said
to one of the moms and these are like
these are I think probably what what is
when you just come free is that that's
not first generation that's first
generation is me no yeah one before you
that's the all these moms with that
immigrant yeah I'm not gonna said that
word but yeah
no you are please say it it's over
immigrants I wouldn't come when I had to
comes out with a little more hate
immigrants no but so they there I told
one of the moms I said I really like
this what is this he said kimchi and I
was like really she goes yeah you know
how it's made she tells me about how
it's made and I know I find that
fascinating that you bury it and then
you dig it up but they didn't do that
for them before so I said I would I love
this I want more she goes I'll bring you
some tomorrow brings me a 5-gallon glass
jar of kimchi I ate this kimchi for a
[ __ ] year my neighbor my neighbor was
a was a chef named Roy Choi Roy Choi
started a he was my next-door neighbor
and our kids are the same his restaurant
yeah but do I know him personally I
think so I love you Roy and Kim and he
started a thing called kimchi tacos
mm-hmm and I and I saw this [ __ ] five
gallon jar kimchi and he was like you
should make kimchi breakfast tacos and
told me how to do it I made it
oh my life it I dude I ate I having a
kimchi forever but it but and that's why
I'm here I wanted to try it again
nobody loved a man I love kimchi
[Music]